i've always wanted to be a founder my
father was a founder
my uncle has a logging company and my
grandmother's a botanist
so there was a destiny for me that was
to be
a founder of a plant biotech company
i'm maddie hall ceo and co-founder of
living carbon
we're a climate change biotech company
and we use advanced genetic engineering
to grow trees that capture and store
more co2
i used to work at a ai research company
and i was just becoming very passionate
about the
biggest existential threats to humanity
and i think
between artificial intelligence and
climate change those are the biggest two
and there are so many people working on
ai and
ml but with climate change you have a
lot of researchers doing fantastic work
a lot of the policy makers doing
fantastic work but not very many people
that are actually trying to
bring to market new technologies and
actually
take this work that's been done in labs
and bring it to a commercial audience
and
you really need large-scale adoption of
anything to
make a difference in carbon removal
i think to me the american dream means
that you have the luxury
to not just have to work for money but
you can work for
a bigger purpose for impact i wish more
people would be willing to take the risk
to maybe leave a cushy tech job and see
how they can
help contribute to solutions to climate
change whether it's leaving your
post-doc
or you know leaving a product manager
role right now i think a lot of people
don't
have the luxury to work on something
like climate change because they feel
like they have to focus
on their communities and dealing with
all the civil unrest
so i would love a world where there's
equitable opportunity for people to be
able to
start really ambitious projects that
will have a large impact and that anyone
can do that
now more than ever